der bundeskanzler wird niedergebrüllt
ausgepfiffen ausgebucht
das sind szenen aus neuruppin in
brandenburg
am abend hat scholz dort eine seiner
bürgersprechstunden veranstaltet aber
sie hören das war eine bürgermut stunde
gut vor allem über die energiepreise
einige hundert die die kanzler dort
beschimpfen als volksverräter als lügner
unter anderem so ging es dort zu in
neuruppin bei dieser bürgerwut stunde
mit dem kanzler
werden sie den schießbefehl erteilen
niemand in diesem land hat vor dass auf
demonstranten geschossen wird und wer
solche schau mädchen verbreitet es ein
schlimmer propagandist wenn ich das aber
ganz deutlich sagen daß die polizei in
diesem lande sorgt für recht und ordnung
sie sorgt dafür dass wir in einem freien
land leben können sie schützt unsere
sicherheit sie schützt und zwar
alltagskriminalität aber sie schützt
auch demonstrationen damit sie die
freiheit wahrnehmen können auch falsche
überzeugung lautet zu rufen das gehört
zur demokratie dazu und wir werden alles
dafür tun dass sie das auch weiter
können dass die reaktion des kanzlers
auf diese pfiffe
des bundeskanzlers der all das am abend
ja ertragen musste dort in europa im
brandenburgischen viktor wachse unser
bild reporter jetzt vom kanzleramt da
scheint die sonne über dem kanzleramt
aber das täuscht im moment ist
wahnsinnig viel druck da auf dem kanzler
wohl so viel druck wie noch nie in
seiner kanzlerschaft
genauso ist es so viel druck wie noch
nie in der kanzlerschaft in der jungen
kanzlerschaft von olaf scholz der tag an
dem er den kommentar von abbas dann
einfach unkommentiert gelassen hat
geschwiegen hat war ein schwarzer tag
der jetzt zu einer schwarzen woche wird
es läuft nicht gut für den bundeskanzler
gestern wir haben es gerade gesehen
wurde er niedergebrüllt in neuruppin und
morgen steht ja auch noch der
untersuchungsausschuss im bundestag an
für den comic skandal dh es ist wirklich
eine schwierige woche lass uns noch mal
auf diese proteste blicken in neuruppin
die afg unter anderem hatte ja dazu
aufgerufen genau das zu veranstalten
dort und neuruppin aber das ist ja schon
ein protest der sich intensiviert in den
vergangenen tagen in den vergangenen
wochen vor allen dingen in
ostdeutschland er eben jetzt stark auf
die straße getragen wird und dort der
regierung robert habeck annalena
baerbock der fdp auch gestern vor der
fdp-zentrale habe jetzt speziell dem
bundeskanzler entgegen schwappt wie geht
er damit um
er versucht sich sozusagen als teflon
kanzler gar nichts anmerken zu lassen
man hat ja gesehen er war relativ
entspannt für die verhältnisse er hat
sich nicht anmerken lassen was für eine
schlechte woche das für ihn ist er ist
daran gewöhnt dass wir da einfach kurs
hält so zu sagen man hat gerade die
nicht einfach das macht das weiter macht
was er vorher schon gemacht hat sich ans
protokoll hält das dann schon irgendwie
alles in ordnung ist und versucht eben
genau diese art von teflon kanzlerschaft
jetzt weiter durchzuziehen nach diesem
abend der bürgerwut dort in europa ist
er jetzt schon bei der arbeit kam viktor
ist er jetzt schon im kanzleramt
er ist noch nicht da man kann einmal auf
bundestag.de ganz genau sehen was der
kanzler macht und er wird um 10 hierher
kommen hinter mit den ersten termin
haben und wir sind gespannt was sich im
laufe des tages entwickelt ja du hast es
gesagt all das passiert diese bürgerwut
24 stunden nachdem der kanzler einen
seiner größten fehler gemacht hat im
kanzleramt als er den mund hätte
aufmachen müssen vor den augen der welt
und als er aber geschwiegen hat als
palästinenserpräsident abbas im
kanzleramt den holocaust verharmlost hat
scholz geschwiegen die frage jetzt hat
scholz wirklich kanzler format
achter dezember 2023 olaf scholz wird
kanzler ein verwalter ein arbeiter wird
zum regierungschef wird zum macher
ernannt vielleicht auch weil über seinen
konkurrenten nur gelacht wird seitdem
stellen sich viele immer öfter die frage
ist olaf scholz zu klein für große amt
denn wer ein land führt wer auf der
bühne steht muss schnelle und richtige
entscheidungen treffen nicht so wie
jetzt beim besuch des
palästinenserpräsidenten abbas der
verharmlost den holocaust vergleicht
israel mit der nazi diktatur und olaf
scholz der kanzler schweigt im denkbar
schlechtesten moment widerspricht der
holocaust verharmlosung nicht schlimmer
noch es folgt ein händeschütteln die
pressekonferenz ist beendet
erst auf bild-nachfrage am abend sagt
scholz dass jegliche holocaust
relativierung unerträglich und
inakzeptabel sei zwölf stunden brauchen
olaf scholz und seine mitarbeiter dann
noch um sich empört über die unsäglichen
aussagen des palästinensischen
präsidenten auf twitter zu zeigen für
viele reicht das nicht sie sagen der
kanzler hätte sofort reagieren müssen
sich zu gesicht deutschland hatte
führung bei olaf scholz bestellt er
hatte führung versprochen geliefert wird
zögern und zaudern beispiel krieg gegen
die ukraine olaf scholz schafft es nach
ausbruch des krieges wochenlang nicht
ein klares bild abzugeben einen plan und
eine haltung zu waffenlieferungen zu
präsentieren er wirkt dünnhäutig und
apathisch er wirkt genervt vom krieg
er kann kanzler nicht so kritiker ganzer
stolz wirkt überfordert
überlastet er muss sich fragen ob er der
verantwortung die das kanzleramt mit
sich bringt wenig gerecht werden kann
schon in hamburg war der damalige erste
bürgermeister scholz bekannt für seine
nicht antworten und dafür dass er in
unangenehmen situationen keine haltung
zeit den g-20-gipfel bezeichnet er als
hafengeburtstag als hamburg brennt und
in gewalt und chaos versinkt sitzt
scholz in der elbphilharmonie
typisch meint christoph ploß er kennt
scholz aus seiner zeit in hamburg und
aktuell aus dem bundestag da wird das
jetzt im pressesprecher in die schuhe
geschoben
olaf scholz übernimmt nicht die
verantwortung für sein fehlverhalten
gestern und das ist auch etwas was wir
aus hamburg kennen hat olaf scholz in
wahlkämpfen immer davon gesprochen dass
er für und hat ja sogar diesen spruch
geprägt wehrführung bestellt bekommt sie
auch am ende haben wir genau das
gegenteil bekommen und das gleiche gilt
nun auch unser land führung unter
kanzler scholz fehlanzeige stattdessen
nimmt regierungssprecher steffen
hebestreit die schuld auf sich und
erklärt warum der kanzler sich nicht zur
holocaust aussage geäußert hat dann habe
ich schon gesagt habe den fehler gemacht
nicht darauf zu reagieren bzw
nicht selber eine lücke zu lassen so
dass der bundeskanzler reagieren kann
das ist etwas was ich wie gesagt auf
meine kappe nehmen klingt so als hätte
man da keinen fehler gemacht ich finde
wenn fehler passieren dann muss man das
auch klar aussprechen und muss sagen ja
das war meiner wie führung und
durchsetzungsvermögen gehen zeigen
robert habeck wirtschaftsminister
annalena baerbock außenministerin und
damit liegen sie in der wählergunst weit
vor dem kanzler
annalena baerbock liefert sich mit ihrem
türkischen amtskollegen auf offener
bühne einen schlagabtausch
auch bei ihrem besuch in der ukraine
weit vor stolz wirbt sie ehrlich bewegt
und klar in ihrer haltung robert habeck
managt derzeit die gas und energiekrise
verhandelt mit neuen lieferanten und
schwört die bevölkerung auf einen harten
winter ein deshalb fragen sich derzeit
viele wäre habeck der bessere kanzler
gewesen
das nagt an dem kanzler bild reporter
karl viktor wachs dort vorm kanzleramt
der kanzler unter druck wie nie speziell
in dieser woche lasst uns einmal noch
mal auf diese arbeitswoche des kanzlers
blicken die für ihn ja schon eine woche
der wahrheit ist
absolut k s ist eine woche der wahrheit
ist eine woche in der er eigentlich
einen ätzenden termin für ihn nach dem
anderen hat und der gipfelt jetzt morgen
am freitag auch noch in dem ausschuss wo
er sich dann äußern werden muss zum
sexskandal auch der nagt an ihm man
sieht im moment wenn man die
schlagzeilen verfolgt also nicht nur
erzählungen über die entgleisung von
herrn abbas und das schweigen von herrn
scholz sondern auch die verwicklung aus
seiner zeit als hamburger bürgermeister
in diesen sehr komplizierten finanz
skandal
danke der kanzler unter druck wie nie
sagte unser bild reporter karl viktor
wachs dort vom kanzleramt nach dieser
bürgerwut stunde am abend in neuruppin
für den bundeskanzler
[Musik]